[CLAPPING]
LASZLO SYROP: All right.
Well thank you, Regina, for
having us and hosting us,
and for the kind words.
Before I get started, I'll
do a quick presentation.
But just to give you a
sense of my background,
I graduated in May
from the Wharton School
at the University
of Pennsylvania.
And before that, I worked
in management consulting
at BCG and in private equity.
I graduated from
Brown University.
I grew up in Los Angeles,
and I now live in New York.
I'll try and take a
very short 10 minutes
to just give you a
little bit of background
on our organization,
the Wharton 22s.
And hopefully that will lead to
a rich discussion between all
of us and all of you.
So who are the Wharton 22s?
As Regina mentioned, we
are a student-led group
of Wharton MBAs.
Our membership is
all-male, and we
work in close concert
with the Wharton Women
in Business
Association, or WWIB,
who are Wharton's premier
women's affinity group.
Because it always comes up,
I'll tackle it early-- the name.
Our name, the Wharton 22s, is
a tongue-in-cheek reference
to the current pay gap between
men and women in America.
The average-- median woman makes
22% less than the median man.
And yes, it is a little
bit of a weird name.
I won't take credit
for it myself.
And it's not the only issue
that we concern ourselves with.
But it is a great
opportunity for us
to start a dialogue
about gender issues
when we introduce ourselves
to a new audience.
We have 34 male officers
and 320 pledged supporters.
And when we talk about
pledged supporters,
this is the pledge that
we're referring to.
I'll let you all
read it for yourself,
but essentially it boils down
to three basic commitments
we ask of men at Wharton.
And that's a commitment
to support gender equity
efforts around us, a
commitment to understand
our own role and
our own actions,
and a commitment to connect
productively with others.
And through our
efforts, to date,
the 320 male pledgees of
the 22s represent about 1/3
of all men at Wharton.
We the 22s hope to see a more
equitable world with respect
to gender issues.
And we recognize that the
business community plays
a vital role in shaping that.
Unfortunately, there's still a
lot of progress yet to be done.
Recognizing both that
men are frequently
the sources of gender
inequity and that many parts
of the business world are
currently disproportionately
male, we feel that
male-led activism
can be an effective
complement to the efforts
of our female counterparts.
And this is an idea, frankly,
that we can't take credit for.
The Wharton 22s was
initially founded
with the support of WWIB,
who saw this as an area
for growth and
engagement, and sought out
a group of male
leaders on campus
to help foster these efforts.
That said, our ethos is one of
recognizing that privilege--
and in our case,
male privilege--
imposes more obligations.
As men, we inhabit
spheres where women may
be absent or underrepresented.
And as men, we
have opportunities
to engage men who may be
resistant to women's voices.
Lastly, as men, we often benefit
from an unequal status quo.
And for those of us who
are involved in the 22s,
we recognize an obligation to
help change that status quo.
So that's a very
high-level overview
of who we are as the 22s.
But why are we relevant
for a company like Google?
I would argue that the
challenges that we faced
in forming, organizing, and
sustaining our organization
are actually very similar
to the ones that you
would face at Google, or frankly
at any large organization.
And because of that,
our experiences
can be valuable for the
community here as you think
through whether this is a
strategy you want to pursue
and, if so, how you
might go about doing it.
There are five specific areas
that I would highlight quickly
which we've grappled
with in building the 22s.
And I'm going to cover
them pretty quickly,
but hopefully we can
continue to build on some
of these in our discussion.
So first is the existential
question of representation.
What does it mean to
be a male ally, what
does it mean to be
an ally, and what's
the role of men in a
conversation that primarily
affects women.
How do we stand
up for the issues
that we believe need
change without drowning out
the voices of women who have
been active in the discussion
for so long.
I think this is really
important for us.
And for the men in
attendance, if you leave here
with one thing, I would
say remember this.
Our view is that being an ally
requires humility, empathy,
and courage, but
humility first of all.
And that's the
humility to understand
that you don't have the
same lived experience
of your female allies.
And rather than viewing
yourself as a change agent who
has all the answers, instead
see your mission as one
to listen, to understand,
and to support.
I think, you know, just
to reiterate one thing,
which is in the
business community,
and I think particularly
in technology,
there's an attitude that
coming with a solution first,
being willing to move
fast and break things,
is the solution
to all situations.
And I think that often we
forget that, in social issues,
sometimes listening, taking
a step back, admitting what
we don't know, and being
willing to be wrong
and being willing
to be vulnerable
can be even more impactful.
Second, and more practically,
the question of recruitment.
How do you get men to care
about this issue who should
be part of a male ally group.
We take a multi-pronged approach
here to the work that we do,
and we try to appeal to
men on multiple levels,
ranging from the pure
ethical-- the purely ethical
to the more self-interested.
Some of the things we
emphasize at Wharton
are the ability to be
an inclusive leader
and collaborator in teams.
I think there was an era
where the idea of being
a global manager was new to
the business school curriculum.
And where we are
today, I see the view
of being an inclusive leader at
the forefront of what it means
to be a successful manager.
Additionally, we'd
like to emphasize
that these are not
purely women's issues
that we talk about.
Family leave policies
can affect both men
and women in the workplace.
And we also address questions
of work/life balance
for men, the
question of what does
it mean to be an active father.
How do you address
issues of masculinity.
And then lastly, it's obviously
the right thing to do.
And I think most people's
hearts are in the right place,
and we hope to help equip
them with better tools
to be that change they
want to see in the world.
Third, programming.
What do we actually do
as a male ally group,
and what tangible
measures do we take.
We have a basic
framework for how
we try to engage with
our audience at Wharton.
And that includes awareness,
dialogue, and activism.
For each of these, we try
to develop programming
relevant for folks at
Wharton to-- first, to build
their awareness that gender
inequities still exist,
and what those are;
to foster dialogue,
to help them connect
with their peers,
and to listen to the experiences
of their female counterparts;
and to empower them
to be effective
advocates for change in the
environments they go into.
In terms of awareness,
we publish articles
in The Wharton Journal.
We invite speakers to campus.
We employ social media
campaigns to raise awareness
of various gender issues.
And we have Lunch
Lecture series so people
can feel educated about
the topics that we discuss.
To foster dialogue, we host
Candid Dinner Discussion
series, where people
can have a safe space
to engage on these topics
and feel that they have
a forum within the
business school community
and within the
professional environment
to talk about these
types of issues.
And we host workshops to
help people understand
the various ways that
intersectionality can play
into this mission, as well.
And lastly, in terms of
activism, the first step
we have is having the existence
of the 22s and our officer
board so that men who are
interested in the subject
can get more involved,
and progressively
continue to get involved in
the issue of gender equity.
And secondly, we have
intensive workshops
where we work on empowering
MBA candidates with the tools
to make change
and intervene when
they return to the real world
and their professional lives.
Fourth, the topic of discomfort.
How do you manage
the awkward and often
threatening feelings that
can come with engaging
on a touchy subject.
All of our work hopes
to create a climate
where folks feel safe discussing
these issues, empowered
to ask questions, and
comfortable being vulnerable.
But I think the biggest
impact that we've
had in creating this type
of an outcome at Wharton
is by existing as a group,
by setting an example
that this is an
appropriate conversation
topic, by acting as role models
for other men who might want
to engage on the topic, and
creating a critical mass that
shows the outside world that
this is a topic of interest
to young business leaders.
And lastly, what's
the best structure
for a group like this.
How do you continue to
sustain an organization
like this, particularly
in a business school
environment, where we
have 50% annual turnover.
I think today these are
probably the areas where
we have the most to grow.
But luckily, being
in business school,
we have a lot of
opportunities to experiment
and try to get the model right.
I know 10 minutes probably isn't
enough time to familiarize you
with everything that we've
done and all of the thinking
that we've done about the issue
of being a male ally group,
but hopefully this
gives you a little bit
of a taste for our work, how
we think about our mission,
and leads to a
good conversation.
So with that, I'll thank
you for hosting us today.
It's really a pleasure
to have the opportunity
to share our efforts with
such a large audience.
And if I forget to make
the plug again later,
I'll direct you all
to learn more about us
at our website,
www.wharton22s.com.
And just to build on
Regina's earlier story,
we'd been saying for a long
time we needed a website.
But when I got a Facebook
message from Regina
saying that she'd
heard us on the radio,
it dawned on me and
our head of marketing
that we really needed a little
bit more of an official way
to get in touch with us.
So we can credit Regina with
the creation of our website.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ASHLEY WELLS: My
name is Ashley Wells.
I, like Laszlo, recently
graduated from Wharton in May.
I was at Deloitte
Consulting in DC
for four years before school.
And, fun fact, I did my
MBA internship at Google
last summer.
So I had noogler
training in this room,
and it feels very familiar
and exciting to be back
with you guys.
So thanks so much for
having Wharton here
represented at Google.
ERIC YOUNG: Awesome.
Thank you for joining us.
Kan, you want to introduce
yourself to the half
the room you may not know?
[LAUGHING]
KAN KOTECHA: Kan Kotecha
I've been here now 18 months,
and I'm responsible for a
group called Biz Apps that
does everything from
[INAUDIBLE] engineering
for GDC through to what
we do with [INAUDIBLE].
Great to be here.
ERIC YOUNG: Perfect.
My name is Eric Young.
I joined Google six
months ago, so I
guess I'm no longer
a noogler, but super
excited to be here today.
I run a team called
Supply Chain Systems.
I'm one of Kan's peers.
So perhaps I'll start
with the first question.
One of the unique things you
did was forming a male allies
group.
Can you tell us
more about why you
think it's so important
and critical to bring men
into the conversation,
and what you
hope to gain by their
engagement and involvement?
LASZLO SYROP: Yeah.
I think I touched on it
earlier, but for us, there's
a recognition that it's not
solely the role of those
who are disadvantaged by the
status quo to see change,
that those in a
position of privilege
have an opportunity and
also a moral responsibility
to be a part of that change.
And I think the practical
matter is in the business world,
there are a lot of
environments where women
are absent or underrepresented.
And so it's incumbent on
us to use our position
in those spheres to be an agent
of change, and frankly, as men,
to also educate ourselves
about what issues are faced
by our peers and
to look internally
to see what part of the
situation we play a role in.
ASHLEY WELLS: Definitely.
And I agree with everything
that Laszlo just said.
But to offer a
different perspective,
I think it's important
for men and women
to be engaged in the
conversation on gender equality
and equity, because it's,
frankly, a business imperative.
Just to give an
example, Google actually
led a very pioneering
study, Project Aristotle,
on what makes teams effective.
And what makes teams effective,
the number one factor
is psychological
safety in a team.
And psychological safety
is built on empathy
and it's built on communication
and trust within a team.
And it's where each team
member can come each day
and be their full,
authentic self.
And how can we expect
our teams to show up
every day with their
full authentic selves
without the presence of
diversity among our teams,
as well as inclusive
practices within our teams?
KAN KOTECHA: And
interesting that you've
chosen Wharton 22's group.
And how did you think about
perhaps augmenting or being
a joint force with Wharton
Women in Business group?
So [INAUDIBLE] then that's
inclusive, it's a joint force.
So just us understand why
it was important to have
this parallel initiative there.
LASZLO SYROP: I think
there's a few things
we took into consideration.
I'd say first off, we worked
very closely in concert
with WIB, and so we don't
operate 100% independently.
I think we communicate.
Ash and I certainly
communicated a lot,
and with Ashley
as co-presidents,
we communicate a lot
about what efforts
we're focusing on,
getting by and making sure
that we're on the right track.
But in terms of how we
specifically target and engage
men, I think our
mission is slightly
different from that of WIB.
And I'll let you talk about
what WIB does more broadly.
But I think for
us, the question is
more squarely about
gender inequity,
and particularly about
what men can do about that.
And so one, that's
looking at educating men
about things that
maybe haven't been
a part of their consciousness.
It's creating content for that.
That's a unique experience,
because I think for women,
this is something that they've
faced every day of their life
and every day of their
professional career.
For men, this may
be a new topic.
And so that approach
is different.
I think secondarily,
there are issues
that are specific to men that
are of interest to them around,
what type of father do you
want to be, how are you going
to balance that
with your career,
how do family leave
policies affect you.
And I think by having
an independent group,
we're able to focus on curating
content for that audience
directly.
ASHLEY WELLS: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think that
one thing that's
really important-- and
I'll speak directly
to the men in the
group, is something that
was really special
about the Wharton 22s
is that it is really a male
initiative that's run by men.
It is not Wharton
Women in Business
telling the men what to do or
how to run their organization.
And that was really important
to us from the beginning,
was that this is something that
men took initiative on and led
in partnership with one another.
The only other thing
I'll say in terms
of Wharton Women in Business
specific programming,
I think that there will always
be a very important space
for organizations that-- you're
a part of days like today,
where women have
time with just women
to connect on a lot
of the issues that
are important to us.
And we need that safe
space among women.
At the same time, I think there
are so many men that say, tell
me what to do, or how do
I get involved with this,
or this is a conversation that
I want to be a part of as well.
And so having an
organization or a male allies
group such as the 22s is
that forum for so many men
that want to be a part
of the conversation.
ERIC YOUNG: Perfect.
So gender diversity, as
you kind of touched on,
can be a tough topic for many.
People often don't know how
to engage in the conversation.
I think some of us may have
seen Grace Hopper's conference
that had a male allies
panel that went sideways.
Others of us may have
saw it firsthand.
Some read about it.
What advice would
you give to the men
in the room who are looking
to get involved in terms
of overcoming some of
the fears and the ways
to engage effectively
with the group?
LASZLO SYROP: I
think it goes back
to really thinking about
what the role of an ally is,
and being willing to listen.
I'd say the first thing is to
recognize that you don't have
all the answers,
that you don't have
the same shared experience.
And so if gender is an issue
you want to engage with,
ask questions of the
women in your lives
and when you're close to.
Be open to hear the
feedback that they give you,
and consider how you can
make positive change.
But look for that direction.
Be willing to be vulnerable
about what you don't know.
Be willing to ask questions.
I think be willing
to fail, also.
Be open to being called out.
Be open to being wrong.
Be open to putting your foot
your mouth and making sure
that you clearly communicate
this is something
that you're interested in,
that you're engaged in,
that you're trying
to be better about.
And you'll find
partners along the way.
I think if we look at the
membership, the officers
of the 22s, we
certainly have folks
who have been involved in
gender issues and social justice
issues before.
We also have folks who
have come to us and said,
this is something I
want to learn about.
This is a weakness of mine,
and that's why I'm joining.
I think of one
particular member of ours
who comes from a background in
the military and special ops.
He had never worked with a
woman before in his entire life.
He's coming to business school.
He has two young daughters.
And he said, listen, I
recognize that I don't even
know what I don't know.
I want to be a part of this.
And this is going to be an
initiative for me to grow.
And so I think about
that example as someone
raising their hand and
saying, I'm willing to fail,
but I'm willing
to-- but I'm also
ready to listen rather
than proffer a solution.
ERIC YOUNG: I think one of
the great things you shared
with me just last week
in our conversation
was the advice to speak
with and not speak for.
I thought that was
particularly powerful.
And I thought it was a
good takeaway overall,
and the willingness as you say,
to make yourself vulnerable,
be willing to make mistakes.
People are there to be
supportive and work through it.
KAN KOTECHA: I would add
my own comments to that.
As we talk about gender
inequality or diversity,
this is something that I think
is important to all of you.
Ashley, I'll echo what
you said as well, which
is if you look at how technology
specifically is shaping
everything that we
do, and as females
as 51% of the population,
20% representation in tech,
it represents such
a huge opportunity
to influence every aspect of
our society and the economy.
And I think not
addressing it, I think
it's catastrophic in many ways.
But it is uncomfortable.
So I know when I'm writing
an email, whether it's
about gender inequality or
about diversity in the workplace
or civility in the workplace,
I have a lot of help,
but I spend a lot of time
almost dissecting every word,
because I'm really worried that
I'm going to offend somebody.
Do I use the black community,
or how do I describe people?
And it's interesting for you
to say, be prepared to fail.
That's very hard to do,
because you're actually
worried that, OK, did I
inadvertently offend somebody?
And then how do you even--
I don't know whether you've
had the experience
of, how do you recover
from something like that?
It's hard.
That's very hard.
ASHLEY WELLS: So going
back to the presence
of psychological safety
in the workplace,
it also needs to be a
safe space for managers
to sometimes make mistakes.
And as a manager
or a leader, it's
your responsibility
to communicate
to your teams, look,
I'm open to feedback,
all kinds of feedback,
and that feedback
can include difficult topics.
And I want you to come
to me if there is ever
a time when you've experienced
discomfort or a time
when maybe it could have
been more sensitive or more
inclusive.
I want you to bring that to me.
And I think that speaks so
much to just your confidence
as a leader, and also
your competence, frankly,
in leading an inclusive team.
LASZLO SYROP: I
think also empathy
plays a large role,
because yes, it's
always going to be difficult
to put yourself at risk.
It's always going
to be a question
about what's expected of me
and what's the right action.
But if you start with
empathy and thinking
about, OK, let me put myself
in someone else's shoes,
I think that often
helps to clarify things.
It's not a cure all.
It certainly doesn't
work in every situation,
and sometimes it's difficult
to adequately imagine
what someone else feels.
But starting from
that perspective,
I think, can help
you understand what
you should be watching
for, and look in the mirror
from outside of yourself.
ERIC YOUNG: Obviously
personal discomfort
is one of the key reasons
that perhaps men don't
engage in the conversation.
What are the other
hurdles you see
about getting more engagement
in the conversation
and in the dialogue?
LASZLO SYROP: I think the
biggest one we face is apathy.
I think at Wharton, and I
imagine at a place like Google,
you encounter very few people
who are actively antagonistic,
who say, I don't like this,
I don't want gender equality,
I don't want gender equity.
I think the question is more,
why does this affect me?
Why is this my problem?
Why do I care?
And so I think that is one of
the main reasons as 22s, it's
important for us, I
think, as men to model
the behavior of being
engaged, of caring,
and of being comfortable talking
about some of these issues
and how it affects us.
And so that's-- how do you get
people in the door is a sort
of tactical challenge--
what type of programming is
interesting, how do
you market events,
how do you invite people to
be part of the discussion.
And there's a lot
of ways to do that.
But I think the core
challenge is just,
how do you engage people?
And I think often, that's
bringing it home for them.
Sometimes we talk about no
matter who you are as a man,
there are women in your
life who you care about.
And if you are open to listening
to what they experience,
it's hard not to have empathy.
And whether that's a female
colleague, a female manager
or a mentor, a family
member, a daughter,
that's often a starting point
for, I think, a lot of men
to recognize that they
care in some respect.
Let me go a little bit deeper
and ask questions and listen.
And I think that's
a snowball effect.
As you start to become
more open to engaging,
you find more reasons
why it's important to you
for your personal ethics,
for how it affects you
and your family structure,
whatever that may be.
ERIC YOUNG: I think it's a great
point you hit on, both in terms
of awareness-- unconscious
bias is something we offer here
at Google to teach
all nooglers as part
of their onboarding, the reality
that unconscious bias exists.
I personally remember taking
that for the first time
before joining Google at Grace
Hopper's conference last year.
And I remember thinking in the
room, I can outsmart the test.
I can do well.
I'm sure that this is not
going to surface anything.
But it was super real
to watch the room
go through this
kind of experience,
and see just how much and
how reality this really
is a situation and
opportunity to address.
I think a lot of
people walked away
from that with a
new appreciation
about the importance, to
make a focused effort here.
KAN KOTECHA: I've got one
other question, if I may.
Laszlo, you touched upon
not having all the answers,
and the importance of
listening, which I think nobody
would disagree with.
Lately, in some of
the conversations
I'm having, I think people
want a sense of actions.
Let's do something about it.
If we don't do
something about it,
this industry in
20 years' time is
going to look very much
like it does today.
And in fact, if you look
over the last 20 years,
very unfortunately,
very little has changed.
We were just talking
about this earlier,
that there seems to be
this magic 20% number-- 20%
of females in Congress, roughly
20% of females in technology,
that we seem to be stuck here.
So in your experience
in this journey,
when is the transition
point from going from,
hey, I'm listening,
I kind of get it,
I'm addressing my own biases, to
some of the actions that you've
seen be successful around
changing the narrative
and really making
the kind of impact
that we'd all like to
see with gender equality,
and I think other
issues of diversity.
LASZLO SYROP: I think that's
certainly the challenge.
It's how to get over that
hump, and we probably
don't have the answer for that.
I think our
perspective is the best
way to get there, to whatever
the specific situation is,
the best way to get
to effective action
only comes once you've
had real discourse
and an inclusive
discourse, and one where
people are willing to
go beyond putting a put
a bright face on things.
And so where we focus is
getting men into that discussion
and opening their minds
and opening their ears
to hearing a
different perspective.
So I think that's where
we've traditionally focused.
But unless you have that raw,
honest discourse and inclusive
discourse, it's hard to have a
sustainable solution, I think.
ASHLEY WELLS: So if
I could just build
on that-- just want to answer
the question in two ways.
One, at Google, you guys
are really fortunate.
You have the foremost innovative
people operations practice
basically in the
world that are looking
at hard problems on
diversity and inclusion,
on things like hiring and
retention and big systemic
problems.
So you guys are fortunate
that you have that.
I think when it comes to play
in terms of action oriented
for the people in
this room is really
about small day-to-day actions
that each of us can take.
So it could be as
simple as calling out--
being, let's say, a male
manager and calling out
other people on the team who may
interrupt women on your team.
It could be looking at who are
you recommending for promotion
each year, and is there
gender representativeness
amongst those you're
thinking of promoting?
And if not, asking yourself
the hard questions around why.
And I really like the
unconscious bias trainings.
We're looking to bring
those to Wharton as well.
What I think is great about
those is the actual trial
and error of people
practicing out,
what does it mean to me
to take a small action,
and then actually implementing
that in the workforce?
They need the practice.
KAN KOTECHA: That's
great advice.
I really like the way that
you-- you say it well.
We can all make a difference,
and it doesn't have
to be these gigantic leaps.
But the little things--
making this environment
the best environment that we
can make it for everybody,
is just so important.
And one of the things that I was
thinking about this conference,
that I hope you guys have
all got out of it today--
and by the way, I use guys in
a gender-neutral way, which--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I probably got myself
into trouble just there.
ERIC YOUNG: We'll
edit the video clip.
KAN KOTECHA: Whoops.
Talk about mistakes.
People-- and I forgot
my train of thought.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC YOUNG: I can
complete it for you.
KAN KOTECHA: Small things.
Thank you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ERIC YOUNG: I think there
was a great quote that
was shared with me
that kind of summarizes
both the points, which is the
standard that you walk past
is the standard you accept.
And I think that was a
very powerful quote to me.
I think there's a
lot of small things
that we can each do in
our everyday interactions.
And it's those small things,
it's the cumulative efforts
of many people engaging
and actually speaking up,
recognizing both the supportive
work that's being done
as well as providing feedback,
assuming best intent,
but providing feedback
so that we can all
kind of hone our communication
or perform better.
So I certainly want
to recognize that.
If you see something, definitely
take a moment to recognize it.
I want to thank our panelists
for their time today.
I really appreciate all
the time and discussion.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]